alors je paye beaucoup trop d'impôts
avant la vie ça je le dis franchement
mais dans l'autre côté qu'est ce que tu
veux je gagne aussi pas mal de b donc
faut bien que je paye des impôts donc ça
me dérange pas tu vois je ne quitte pas
c'est pas parce que mélenchon sera
premier miss il alors il le sera jamais
moi vivant
et je n'avais pas cacher mon blé je mens
d'arrêt parce que si la cie la france
devient ce qu'est mélenchon qui de
retour depuis qu'ils retournent
d'amérique du sud la révolution
on n'a pas besoin de faire des manifs en
ce moment on n'a pas besoin de casser
des magasins on n'a pas besoin de
d'emmerder les gens qui travaillent la
révolution c'est bon pour la colombie
mais on n'est pas en colombie